you know if I didn't know better I would
say that these movies are now
deliberately trying to provoke me
Justice League vs Teen Titans guys I'm
gonna have to get into spoilers talking
about this one so if you want spoiler
free version of this review here it is
it sucks
great move along I suppose I should
qualify that slightly I can't say at
this point definitively whether or not
these movies are actually getting worse
I feel like they are but honestly I
there's nothing I can really point to
that makes this objectively a worse
movie than Batman vs. Robin or even son
of Batman but the thing is each time I
knew one of these comes out and it
doesn't get better it just does the same
horrible boring infuriating stuff over
and over and over again it makes me hate
it more every time so at this point
every time they crank out a new turn in
this continuing continuity it just makes
me insane that that they're making this
instead of a follow up to the wonderful
Wonder Woman animated film but plot
let's get into plot let's see well this
largely revolves around Damian Wayne
being a dick big surprise is this are
they ever gonna bother trying to have a
story arc for this kid because he hasn't
changed three movies now we've had him
in he hasn't budged an inch he's still
the Defiant arrogant little son and
honestly he is the worst year that I
have ever seen him because at this point
he's been Batman's partner for a while
he's got no excuse to still be going by
with strangers in a session my
grandfather grabovo taught me to be like
this me me me me but I don't care what
the character justification is three
movies and he's spouting the same crap
I'm gonna try and keep my rants about
Damian to a minimum but I am just gonna
say this I have never in the history of
watching any entertainment that I can
think of have wanted a character to die
as badly as I want Damian Wayne to die
usually when there's a character is
something that I don't like I just wish
they weren't there I wish they were
right now they more I don't actually
want to watch the character diet
watch this kid die I would kill him
before I would kill Jar Jar Binks so
anyway it opens with actually a decent
action sequence wire the Justice League
faces off against the Legion of Doom in
front of the Hall of Justice
oh I'm sorry as it is explained in the
movie itself by a newscaster what social
media has dubbed the Hall of Justice
because that's how above it all this
series is at this point they can't even
call it that they have to say social
media dub did that you know how crazy
social media just call it the damn thing
anyways the league is fighting him and
Robin is basically on heard the innocent
people out of danger duty which he's
doing with explosives first of all and
then second of all he decides he's
suited for other stuff and he just goes
off and does his own thing directly
against Batman's orders ie he's a dick
he's always a dick big surprise well
Batman's finally had it with his being a
dick and he pawns him off on the Teen
Titans which in this case consists of
Starfire Raven Beast Boy and Blue Beetle
if you're thinking cyborg should be in
there well he would be but in this
continuity he's part of the Justice
League so no I suppose I'll pause and
mentioned the highlights here because
Beast Boy is one of them he's fun he's
energetic he's funny I like the way they
use his powers unlike how he uses his
powers in combat and there are a couple
of decent action seasons the one at the
opening which is pretty good but it's
ancillary to the story that's happening
and there's one towards the end which is
pretty decent but I'm gonna have to
explain why later because I'm gonna have
to explain why all the other fights in
between these two suck
so anyways Damian's now on the Teen
Titans and he treats them like a dick
the only one that apparently the movie
thinks he bonded with is Raven I don't
know where this film thinks that
happened because I didn't see it there's
one incredibly cheesy bonding montage
and it is the most generic crap ever
because guess what it happens out of
fare and we see him on the ferris wheel
and we see them get cotton candy and we
see them play the games it's it's every
generic bonding montage that you have
ever seen and you know what I'm gonna
pause right here the voice acting is for
the most part fine Damian's insufferable
but he has been since
something was introduced but the other
one who doesn't work is the other
pivotal character of the story which is
Raven now they aren't using any of the
voice actors who have done the Teen
Titans in the various TV shows before
these characters now and they really
should have because the voice actress
who's done Raven on TV is perfect
because one way that has to do is
actually really really difficult she has
the sound disaffected and uninterested
and yet still convey some level of
emotion and get you invested in her as a
character that's really hard to do and
the actors who they brought in to do
Raven this time can't do it she can only
do the disaffected thing but she can't
sort of put the the background emotion
behind that disaffection so that she
actually reads in the character she just
reads bored the entire thing no matter
what's going on no matter what she's
talking about and as I said Raven ends
up being the other big pivotal character
in this whole story because apparently
her father Trigon has now located her
escaped from a prison she put him in
before and now he's coming after her and
that's where the versus the Justice
League comes in because the big title
fight that that implies is the Teen
Titans against three members of the
Justice League and those members of the
Justice League are possessed by shadow
demons from trigons realm so the title
is really misleading and that fight is
like five minutes tops
and it's not even the last fight of the
movie so it's not even the damn climax
but basically the Justice League get
taken over by demons working for Trigon
trying to get him free the Titans you
know fight to to get things back to the
way they should be and yeah it all works
except there's a ton of internal logic
that doesn't make any sense
Draven trapped him into this crystal
prison that she said can't be destroyed
yet one of the first things we see
happen when she reaches out to it to try
and trap him again is it gets shattered
by a sword just a sword not a magic
sword not a spectral sword not a crypt
and I just a sword smash is this thing
that she says nobody could destroy what
now in the demon realm we get the
one other decent fight which is when the
Teen Titans take on various monsters and
creatures and bizarre shadowy thinks
that is the other good fight in addition
to the one that opens the movie and the
reason it's good is because they aren't
fighting other people because the action
scenes when it's just people fighting
people in these movies are boring as
hell it's just punching it's just a heck
of a lot of punching and further all the
powers these people have other things
they're capable of doing this is all
they can think of and it's really really
dull doubly so in animation where you
can draw anything you can have them do
anything and they're just having it's so
boring of course the good guys win
damian joins the Titans all is well in
the world except this franchise oh my
god I'm not writing off DC animation yet
when they break away from this
continuity we still get good things
assault on Arkham was a blast gods and
monsters was amazing I'm still really
hopeful for The Killing Joke but this
this continuity needs to go away I can't
see what the purpose of this being a
continuing continuity at this point is
they have done 0 to take advantage of
this as far as she conserving the only
well they keep coming back to is Batman
over and over and over again which has
been completely changing bite Damian
now if you're watching this you might be
wondering why I haven't done Batman bad
blood first because technically that
came out before this I just I haven't
gotten to it yet this is the one that I
happen to get my hands on first and I
don't want to do Batman bad blood I
really really really really really don't
I will
b'hala wanna so Justice League vs Teen
Titans have you seen it if you have I'm
sorry what are your thoughts on about it
what are your thoughts about this
continuity in general do you think it
can still be salvaged have you actually
enjoyed it whatever's the case drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it don't forget to like
subscribe follow me on twitter at
council of geeks check out the council
of geeks podcast on itunes and stitcher
and until next time this council is
adjourned